a cocktail please what kind a strong one
[Music]
hi I'm Hannah I'm the world's ok ass mom
and my husband needs a haircut he won't
let me touch it to wear the hat every
day but I have an idea because we're all
home kids are born they need stuff to do
I think it'd be really funny to let the
kids choose Nats and hair cut and color
I let them do it to me under Matt's
supervision I ended up with magenta hair
which is my least favorite color so I
think it's time for a little bit of
payback let the kids pick Matt's hair
color and see what happens okay I have a
question for you guys what if daddy
would let you would you want to pick his
haircut and hair color yeah you want a
blue mohawk we're talking about daddy's
right now should we go look at some
hairstyles and some colors let's do it
ready all hands in 1 2 3
good I think Matt's a little bored
himself to be honest and Matt needs
something fun in his life so that's why
he agreed to do this and I will take
full advantage of it Matt is vulnerable
right now
he's home with all of us it's three
against one he doesn't have a leg to
stand on right now so it's the perfect
opportunity to do this perfect let's do
it
how about cover
so since Matt couldn't leave the house
to go to uh salon
we brought the salon to our house what
is this we all chose alter egos for this
experience because we really needed to
get into character none of us are actual
hair experts and so we needed to fake it
a little bit Oh Matt goes along with all
of our weird stuff blast him I am just
an office assistant but I'm going to be
doing the hair to face Center for my
training kids plus scissors plus eyes
plus ears Plus face is just not a good
combo I trust them with scissors now but
I don't trust them that much I have
experience cutting the kids hair I've
done it several times and I feel like
I've gotten okay at it the first time I
tried Jackson I actually turned him into
like a 70s Donny Osmond that being said
that's kids hair I've never cut an adult
males hair I realized as we were about
to go into the haircut that I hadn't
ordered the correct tools I needed to
actually cut his hair and I did not have
time to get them in the mail so I was
working with some fresh brand-new unused
kitchen scissors how does this look so
far good but you need to cut this side
more I do I would not say kitchen
scissors are precise at all and they're
probably damaging to the hair itself I
don't think they are in any way meant to
touch anything on anybody's body did you
leave your apparently
girls she has a straight well I am
kitchen lasers
my strategy cutting mats hair is you can
always go shorter we can't undo a
mistake that's been made at very short
so I tried to ease into the cut and keep
it longer and see how I did and then if
I needed to I could always fix it a
little bit shorter what - sure I'm just
trying to texturize okay texturizing I
didn't really know what I was doing what
do you think so far sir it's looking
great
matt has a lot of hair and he has curly
hair and the kitchen scissors just
weren't cutting it so we found an
ancient pair of clippers in the back of
some cupboard in the bathroom you trust
me I whipped those puppies out and I
decided to do like a gradual fade into
the longer part on the top I don't know
what it's called it actually worked okay
I was proud of myself
matsa that I was too timid with them
because I was so afraid of like cutting
his ear off no house is lame I would
never charge anybody for my hair cutting
services but I will say that in a pinch
I think I could do it again and I think
it would be okay I'm still not sure if
Matt hated it or liked it or was okay
with it because I thought it looked good
he seemed a little lukewarm on it but
honestly what was he expecting what time
is it sometimes
awesome time hey guys you ready know
what to do okay go ahead okay it's not
gonna show me how mature you can be okay
Wyatt that's already a little too much
the boys didn't quite understand the
idea of less is more when you're
coloring you really don't need like a
whole glop on each section cuz it does
get on your scalp and it does get on
your skin no no just put it down for a
second
[Music]
Jackson I was trying to remind them to
go a little easy on it and I really
didn't want it to be dripping all over
the bathroom he has a technique don't
question his technique okay yes it's
called the snare all over yes oh I
admire your work the boys technique that
they used was kind of like a plop and
smear the colors that they chose were
green and blue and they wanted to do
kind of a combo so they just did little
patches where ever they could reach it
was kind of a tricky situation for Wyatt
because he was having a hard time
reaching the top of Matt's head so I
don't really know if he could see what
was going on I think at this point Matt
have given up on hoping for something
good and he was just ready to settle on
something yes definitely don't look like
the Joker at all
[Music]
so good coffee water tea a cocktail
please what kind a really strong one
time oh my god
[Music]
I liked the way maths hair looked it was
really subtle because I don't understand
the chemistry of hair color I wasn't
sure how it was going to take to his
hair or how it would show up it actually
really pleasantly surprised me it's
amazing be proud of yourself
I am the boys were thrilled with their
work they had so much fun doing it I
think no matter how it looks they would
have loved it and been proud of
themselves I'm so proud of you guys make
my hair blue I feel great do you feel I
don't have to go anywhere I have to go
out in public after we colored Matt's
hair I knew what was coming I knew the
boys would beg to have theirs done -
this is something they've asked for for
a very long time pretty much ever since
I did my own hair you say you want a
blue hair yeah just blue there but you
want full house what are you gonna get
for it
what are you gonna do you're gonna clean
my room yeah so we'll be a blue haired
family okay so we have to decide whether
or not we'll let the boys color their
hair Jackson has a dress code at school
so he hasn't been able to do it but now
they're not in school for quite a while
I know it's kind of crazy times
yeah we're all kind of looking for some
way to like have fun and you know where
it's cooped up so why it's just kind of
young for it yeah he's got this nice
long girls I know I'm not doing a blue
mohawk are we gonna do it sure all right
we're gonna do it
what else are we gonna do right let's do
it are you sitting on the toilet eating
yes
well your dad might trust the hair we
decided you absolutely can get
blue-haired toilet should we get started
ultimately the deciding factor was its
rinsed out basically a glorified
conditioner it's non-toxic it's very
gentle it's not touching their scalp and
it's not something with fumes that could
impact them in a negative way does that
make me a cool mom I like to think so if
you ask my kids what would they say
probably not when I did blue hair I felt
like that was the color my hair was
always supposed to be and the same kind
of happened for Jackson
it just it suited him so well he looked
really good I surprised myself with how
could it do you think I loved it I was
like oh my gosh
I look amazing Wyatt I went a little
light with the color I didn't want it to
be too saturated all over so it was
pretty subtle I was really happy with it
I thought it looked so cute and I
thought it was just a touch that was you
know not overdoing it but enough so that
he could feel that she had colored hair
who'd you say you look like no I said
Megami you walked up to me what'd you
say I don't know that I look like Billy
Eilish I'm open to letting them have
colored hair I just think it depends on
the life stage we're at in the situation
we're in I obviously want to be
respectful of dress codes and school and
whatever it may be but I am definitely
open to letting them try it again
colored hair has always been my thing
and now it's a family thing and I
couldn't be happier it was a confidence
boost for me that I really
needed and I think it definitely worked
in the same way for my kids maybe not
from that I don't think he will do it
again he earns major cool dad points for
being a really good sport so that's all
I got for today I'm Hanna and if you try
this with anyone in your family or your
kids please tag me on Instagram I want
to see or if you have any ideas for a
future episode or fun activities that we
could try here please message me on
instagram too did a great job
Yin sitting there what I'm really cases
are you have the tools all right exactly
what I need it
[Music]